it's weird uh were you thinking
because because the first gigs that you
did was teaching ftx which is like our
field training exercise which is
[Music]
you know i'm jp and i've talked about
this where i'm like hey jp people don't
they don't need to really like know how
to clear a room yeah it's just it's
funny almost the human instincts that
you have of how you would clear a room
are good enough
to do the ftx's it's not about teaching
people how to you know the tactics of
combat it's just a it's about teaching
them leadership but it's funny
like even the plans they come up with
like we give them a target
their plans are like perfectly fine
they're perfectly fine yeah no sometimes
they're not that great sometimes they
make mistakes but a lot of times it's
like yeah you know what that's that
would work that would work on this
target for real and these are people
that are civilians because
let's face it hitting a target of bad
guys there's it's not rocket science
it's not rocket science to figure out
what you're going to do and we give them
enough basics that they can figure it
out but
for me
you know the the leadership laboratory
that we got to work in when we were
actually in and actually a trade at and
actually seeing platoons go through that
is such a powerful thing because
man when you are in those situations
you feel it and when you like you think
oh i'm good at detaching and then you go
on a run where you're freaking yelling
and screaming and you you know and you
say oh how was that detachment on the
last run as you were yelling and
screaming at everybody and shooting your
weapon a bunch and not and no one took
charge of anything so obvious
when you actually experience it and you
learn that lesson so much more
thoroughly when you actually experience
it's freaking awesome to watch yeah
absolutely i've had messages like on on
instagram or linkedin
where people have gone through our
training it's like hey i had this
situation at work and i thought about
that time when you took the gun away
from me and told me to lead you know
because when they're not detached and
they're just getting after it with their
gun but they're actually in charge
like every now and then i'll take their
gun away and i'm like hey lead now you
can lead because you don't have the gun
and and so you know the right back like
i remember the time you did this to me
or you said this to me
and and i say that at the ftx's i'm like
hey you know
going through that pain
actually solidifies that lesson way more
it's like bruce lee says the pain will
leave you when it's done teaching you
it's one of my favorite quotes
um
and i tell people that too like in my
brief in the morning i'm like hey we're
not here to teach you leadership i mean
we're not here to teach you tactics
we're here to teach you leadership and
in the absence of knowledge because you
don't have any you know knowledge doing
this what do you have to lean back on
your leadership which is simply you
trying to influence another 25 people
towards a common goal
so you're going to have to use all those
tools that we've you know talked about
and the groups that do the best are the
ones that are able to apply it
immediately like they make that
connection
and the ones that struggle are the ones
that you know
can't seem to do that